US News and World Report is out this
morning with the danuel list of best
colleges for 2018 Princeton tops the
list of national universities for the
seventh year in a row it is followed by
Harvard University of Chicago and Yale
they are tied at number three Columbia
MIT and Stanford share fifth place -
university of california schools topped
the list of the best public colleges UC
Berkeley and UCLA are followed by the
University of Virginia the University of
Michigan Ann Arbor and the University of
North Carolina Chapel Hill go Heels this
is the first year us news is offering
postgraduate salary information on 1,000
schools the data provided by pay scale
shows median starting salaries for
alumni with zero to five years of work
experience now topping that list are the
US military and naval academies which
are tied at about $80,000 the California
Institute of Technology is third at more
than 78 thousand dollars salaries were
not used to help determine the overall
rankings those rankings are based on
factors like academic excellence
graduation rates and freshman retention
rates you can find a link to the
complete list at CBS this morning
dot-com